le premier maigret que j'ai tourné il ya
12 ans c'était cécile est morte et je me
grey est passé bien sûr à la télévision
alors le lendemain matin j'ai téléphoné
à barbe qu'il avait fait je lui dis tu
crois pas que ce serait gentil daddy a
quand même dire bonjour à 6 mais non pas
mam dit oui et nous voilà partis
il avait encore sa fameuse maison des
paluns cette grande maison blanche qui
avait l'air d'une clinique et venant de
signer la série pour la télévision
française je me dise immuno a quand même
donné des tuyaux sur le personnage de
maigret tombé sur un homme très
sympathique très maniaque très ordonnée
très rangée et il ne m'a dit qu'une
seule chose il m'a dit voilà quand le
commissaire maigret sort de chez lui le
matin comment dit-il au revoir madame
maigret il l'embrasserai de joux non
très important petite claque sur les
faces
eh bien avec ce détail précis et
judiciaire j'en ai fait 52 j'ai toujours
fumer la pipe
les mauvaises langues disent même que
j'ai été engagé pour jouer maigret parce
que je savais fumer la pipe
mais je me défends en dix ans les
mauvaises langues
bien sûr et vous savez je crois qu'il
faut savoir fumer la pipe quand même un
peu ça beaucoup d'importance tenue par
exemple un dd à des maigret que je viens
de tourner on tournait un jour à 9h du
matin et à 10h j'ai eu l'idée faire le
bilan
savoir où j'en étais cma pitt j'étais en
train de bourrer bas 23e pipe d'un
croyez-moi 10 heures du matin
c'est beau pensez aussi qu'il était dans
la chambre cette nuit et ce que je sais
j'avais compris chose
les médecins m'ont prévenu décrit
deviendra de plus en plus free je sais
qu'à mes confrères qui fut un immense
acteur et pour lequel j'ai une immense
admiration et est sain débat était très
ennuyée par la peep
il n'arrivait pas par exemple à parler
ayant la pipe au bec
or moi j'y arrive de façon intelligible
je crois je crois que c'est très
important parce que la peep fait partie
intégrante du personnage c'est même le
principal accessoire de me grey
car il faut dire aussi que avec le
nombre que j'ai tourné maintenant je
suis pris dans la rue pour maigret
souvent par exemple un petit détail très
sympathique
les agents à paris n'appelle patron
[Musique]